توقفت عجله القرارات السياسيه من عقوبات
على سوريا واخذت هذه المساعدات المشهد
الابرز باتجاهها الى الاراضي السوريه وسط
كارثه انسانيه سيرت الكثيره من قوافل
المساعدات عبر جسور بريه واخرى جويه
اردنيه
اليوم تستعد 14 شاحنه محمله بمساعدات
انسانيه من ادويه ومستلزمات طبيه ومواد
اغاثيه وغذائيه اضافه لحليب الاطفال
للانطلاق وعلى ذات المسار والطريقه سلم
واستلم ما يعني تفريغ حموله الشاحنات
الاردنيه الى اخرى سوريه باتجاهها الى
الهلال الاحمر السوري ومنظمات الامم
المتحده العامله هناك لتوزيعها على الاسر
المنكوبه في سوريا بدانا بالنقل الجوي
عباره عن طائرات وصل الطائره الى مطار حلب
ووصل الطائره الى مطار دمشق حتى يكون هناك
سرعه في الاستجابه اما اليوم
فالاحتياج اختلف وكميه المواد المطلوبه
زادت اكثر فتطلب ان يكون هناك نقل بري سبق
ذلك ارسال طائرتين الى سوريا وتركيا
تحملان فرقه ومعدات انقاذ وخياما
ومستلزمات طبيه واغاثيه وعشر سيارات اسعاف
تجاوبا مع وضع انساني استطاع اي عراقيل
سياسيه
اليوم عن وضع انساني لشقاء وجيران ان في
الاردن وبالتالي تاكيد لا يوجد حديث عن
الموضوع سياسي موضوع انساني وموضوع اغاثي
الاردن سيقوم ان شاء الله بكل مالديه في
هذا الخصوص مسار انساني بعيد عن قيود
يفرضها قانون قيصر الامريكي سلكه الاردن
منذ بدايه الزلزال في سوريا مرسلا سبعه
قوافل مساعدات عبر معبر جابر الحدودي تحمل
معها مواد طبيه وغذائيه واغاثيه
حمله المساعدات التي اطلقتها الهيئه
الخيريه الاردنيه الهاشميه لاقت استجابه
كبيره من الاردنيين ومع اختلاف اشكال
المساعدات دعوات توحدت لتخفيف وطاه
المعاناه عن الاهل في سوريا